John Cena and Nikki Bella step out for
an adorable date night well this is
certainly going to be a great night at
the movies
[Music]
the WWE star and his fiancee looked
happier than ever on Sunday as they
engaged in some serious red carpet PDA
at the premiere of his new flick daddy's
home - I always like doing these with
her we were just discussing that like I
can't do it without her how cute is that
Petey sat down with the 40 year old and
he opened up about his leading lady
who was recently eliminated from Dancing
with the Stars were you shocked when
Nicki got booted off the dance what
stars and how did she handle it uh I
thought she handled it great I think I
am a bit worse when I heard she gets
eliminated inside I'm shocked and I want
to shake my fist and everything but I
have to tell her like I thought she
danced so beautifully she took risks she
really was bold she had moments of
humility like sheshe gave it all and I
think when you you put that much into
something and it doesn't work out the
way you want you still you can't have
any regrets about it so I was just
constantly trying to tell her that
message I'm guessing you'll have a hell
of a first answered your way I know
she'll be good so I think I just may
stand there and do like a teapot thing
I'm gonna do all her stuff you know I
know she'll be good so hopefully
hopefully I can step my game up I have
to say that every junket that we've ever
done every red carpet you ever walk you
have always been styled to the teeth
tell me explain your manners here's
what's going on with it okay I have no
sense yeah I think this looks cool so
that means you're not picking what
you're gonna wear for your wedding I
know I think I will be told I'm gonna
tell you one more on my wedding night
birthdays what wedding day it's her
world I want to do to be very special
for her mmm I just want everybody have a
fun time but I want the day to be
special for her so the little details
like that if I'm if I'm told what to
wear I'll fit in just fine
[Music]